breaking news major science update from
big tech it appears people will no
longer be ostracized from the public
square for questioning the
epidemiological efficacy of those stupid
cloth hankies that dr fauci made us wear
for two years
youtube
has apparently updated its covid
misinformation policy for most of the
epidemic
this would be after fauci told us the
masks work after he told us that the
masks don't work
youtube and other big tech platforms
suspended and de-platformed people for
even questioning the masks i had
episodes of this show taken down because
they were in violation of youtube's
covid misinformation policy of course i
still made fun of the masks but i had to
do it in an indirect way and importantly
in an extremely expensive way when the
episodes of my expensive show were taken
offline
now
just one day after dr fauci announced
his accelerated retirement before
republicans retake the congress
now all of a sudden
it appears google has dropped its rules
on mask commentary
kind of coincidental timing but uh
whatever the reason let me just take
this opportunity to say
the masks were always dumb and they
didn't do jack diddly to stop kovid and
the only thing they ever accomplished
was to make us all breathe stale air and
look like lemmings which our sadistic
and corrupt overlords took great
pleasure in
boy that's nice now that that's out of
the way we have to ask
if making fun of the masks no longer
constitutes scientific misinformation
then how did it ever constitute
scientific misinformation the masks have
not changed the people have not changed
the platform has not changed
even covid with all the variants has not
really changed all that much
if the scientists simply got the masks
wrong
then who's to say they aren't getting it
wrong now
and if all of this
has more to do with politics than with
science or with medicine or with public
health
then why were a handful of big tech
oligarchs able to set the rules for what
can and cannot be debated in the public
square
i'm glad that youtube has decided to let
us tell the truth about the masks again
but the real problem is that youtube
gets to decide in the first place i'm
michael knowles this michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from drania shale
who says damn fauci is even wrong about
when he's leaving his position that's
epic a perfect way for the man to go out
he makes a prediction about when he's
going to leave i'm going to leave
somewhere right around the end of joe
biden's term
and then what do you get two months
later never mind i'm out soon bye see ya
yup he even
got that wrong we got to protect
ourselves from bad technocrats we got to
protect ourselves from epidemics we got
to protect ourselves from freeze fire
flood and the bad guys that's why you
need ring right now go to ring.com
knowles summer is always busy people are
away from their homes quite a bit i was
away not even on vacation i was i was
away because i was in the hospital for a
few days while my wife was giving birth
to my son then i was away yesterday i
was in canada of all places i want to
make sure that my home is protected so
you know about ring you know about the
ring video doorbell you can see and
speak to whoever is at your door no
matter where you are in the world you
could be in the home you could be at the
office you could be in canada you can do
it you know ring has an alarm it's an
award-winning home security system with
available professional monitoring when
you subscribe it's fabulous super easy
to install you can just do it yourself
that's great well ring didn't even just
stop there they have changed the home
security game with ring alarm pro that
is why i have teamed up with ring
you got to be like me you got a gopro
with ring alarm pro they combine a
security system with a fast eero wi-fi 6
router for home security and network
security in one device think about how
much of your life is online make sure
you protect it this busy summer season i
strongly recommend you become a pro like
me you go pro with ring alarm pro
learn more at ring.com
knowles that's ring.com slash knowles
dr fauci can tell which way the wind is
blowing dr fauci might not be great on
pandemics and he might not be great on
the kind of research he's funding like
gain of function research and wuhan and
he might not be great about the efficacy
of masks or vaccines or anything else
but i'll tell you what that guy knows
which way the wind is blowing and he
knows that the political winds are
against him right now and he knows that
if the republicans retake the congress
he's going to have to at least in some
way answer for his four decades of
failure and incompetence and even worse
lies and deceit
and so dr fauci is running as fast as he
can out of washington dc you are going
to see a fouchy-shaped hole in the wall
at nih the second those republicans take
power so he's trying to get out of town
and the reason is that he knows that
they're going to drag him in front of
congress and he's going to have to
answer questions which he says he will
do
but not if he gets tough questions
if once you've retired republicans want
you to go testify would is that
something you would do
sure i certainly would consider that but
you've got to remember
i believe oversight is a very important
part of government structure and i
welcome it and can be productive
but what has happened up to now is more
of a character assassination than it is
oversight
so sure i'd be happy to cooperate so
long as we make it something that is a
dignified oversight which it should be
and not just bringing up ridiculous
things and attacking my character that's
not oversight
that's not i don't want any kind of
oversight that that has them talking
about my career and my record and all
the mistakes i've made and all the lies
i've told and all of the corruption i've
engaged in that's not that's not
dignified
okay i wanted to i wanted to make me
look really dignified
so if for instance the questions are hey
dr fauci why are you so handsome that
would be i think very dignified and hey
jack defaucci you're you're so smart and
charming how do you do both that would
be a very good question to ask but if
they're going to ask me about my failure
on aids and my inability to to make a
new anthrax vaccine after i squandered
gazillions of dollars from the federal
government for it and after my funding
of gains function research in the wuhan
institute of virology and after my lying
about the whole pandemic the entire time
that would be very undignified
what a jerk
what a jerk he says the only way he'll
testify if he gets softballs who cares
especially after
the show trials of the january 6
committee and all the rest of this
democrat
attack on conservatives
after the show trial of steve bannon
after all the rest of it i want them to
subpoena fouchy and then he's if he's
smart he'll just show up and
put on the same kind of soft shoe that
he's done for the past two years and
he'll probably get away with it if he
doesn't show up though i want them to
hold him in contempt of congress
i want them to throw
the book at him
because even if fouchy realizes okay i
got to pull back a little bit here
i got to tone it down a little bit he's
actually said elsewhere
the reason that he's going to retire is
because he thinks that it will make it a
little bit uh less likely that the
republicans in congress go after him
but even on that he's hedging he's i'm
retiring but i'm not really retiring
and i just i think if i'm out of the
spotlight the odds that they go after me
it's much lower
so fauci understands that a little bit
the the technocrats around the world
with the united nations at the world
health organization those guys
they're they're accelerating if anything
if anything they're they they are
feeling empowered to take even more even
more control and even more sovereignty
away from us the head of the world
health organization tedros
adanum gabrizius
did i say that correctly probably not
who cares he uh he said in a speech to
the who quote the pandemic has
demonstrated not only why the world
needs the world health organization but
why the world needs a stronger empowered
and sustainably financed world health
organization i thank all member states
for the historic commitment you made
to a gradually increased assessed
contributions to 50 that would be dr
tedros
the world health organization is in
large part the reason why the covid
pandemic was so bad because the world
health organization covered up for china
during the first several months of the
pandemic
and the world health organization not
only carried water on the danger that
the virus in china posed to the rest of
the world the world health organizat
organization carried water for china on
how the virus began in the first place
flew cover for china when they made up
the ridiculous story about the bats and
the pangolins of the wuhan wet market
instead of where the virus almost
certainly
came out of which was the
wuhan institute of virology which was
funded in part by dr fauci and the nih
in the united states
tedros and the whole wh
made the pandemic worse this is why
donald trump and lots of republicans
said we need to decrease our funding for
the world health organization these guys
not only are they not improving the
public health not only are they taking
away our rights and our liberties
they're actually
making the whole situation far worse
than even when it started and this is
what the libs always do
the libs cause a problem
or they exacerbate a problem and then
they take that problem as evidence that
they need more power
they the people who caused and
exacerbated the problem in the first
place
the problems really really bad give us
more power
you especially see this the clearest
example would be with welfare with
certain welfare programs that create
cycles of dependency the libs will take
a bunch of power and then wields that
power within welfare giving out lots of
money often entrapping people not in a
social safety net but in a spider web
and then as the problem gets worse they
use that as an excuse to say see this is
why you need to give us a lot more money
so that we can expand the programs that
are trapping people in the cycles of
poverty in the first place this is what
they always do
the libs take a lot of power in the
education system then what happens the
educa
the quality of students education
decreases students become much much more
ignorant than the libs point to that
they say this is a huge education crisis
you got to give us more money and power
no guys you it was the fact that you
took all the power in education that
caused the educate education crisis
in the first place and there is a video
out right now from a youtuber james klug
which makes you tremble and weep for
america it's a video of gen z this guy
just goes out on the street asks really
really basic questions to a bunch of
zoomers on the street
and they don't know the answer and the
reason why this is so weird is because
we have been reliably told
our entire lives if you're a young
person let's say you're under
45 you've probably been told your whole
life you're the most educated generation
ever and people are being told this more
and more the younger they are and it
turns out we actually know much much
less than virtually every generation
that came before us it means we need to
protect what assets we do have that's
why you got to check out birch gold text
knolls to
989898 the consumer price index has
reached 40 year highs the latest gdp
numbers confirm the u.s is in a
recession whether the administration
wants to admit that or not now is not
the time to have all your money in the
stock market or tied to the u.s dollar
take action to protect your savings from
a highly turbulent economy
now by diversifying at least some of
your investment portfolio into gold and
silver from birch gold group text knolls
to 989898
birch gold will send you a free info kit
on how to transition an ira or eligible
401k into an ira in precious metals
birch gold will even help you hold gold
in a tax sheltered account for decades
investors have relied on gold and silver
as a hedge against inflation you can too
they've got an a plus rating with a
better business bureau countless
five-star reviews and thousands of
satisfied customers so do it right now
text knowles to 989898
get help from birch gold today that is
knowles canada wles to 989898 to claim
your free no obligation info kit on how
to protect your hard-earned savings with
gold
the youtuber james klug
goes face-to-face with the zoomers
asks them really simple questions here's
what they say
how many stars are on the united states
flag
103
103 100
yeah
obama would have said 32. what ocean is
on the east side of the united states
what
ocean can i google it
[Music]
you guys know this
i know this
i don't know this what country is the
queen of england from
i'm not a political i don't know i
really don't know just take a guess like
what country is the queen of england
from
europe i don't know
i don't know i just took a guess what's
the capital of the united states um
[Music]
there's a capital
what lexi take a guess um
[Music]
i don't know uh probably california yeah
that's probably california it is
not
speaking i think i think it is probably
california it's california just the
california vibe
seems to be taking over the whole
country
really sad
stuff now you might say oh well he just
went out and found the dumbest people he
could find
and
posted their silly gotcha moments
i'm not sure that that's true there was
a survey that was taken by the isi
the intercollegiate studies institute
back in 2007 so this is now 15 years ago
and it was a study of the elite
universities measuring historical and
civic knowledge of incoming freshmen and
graduating seniors
the survey found that the incoming
freshmen knew more than the graduating
seniors that students were becoming more
ignorant the longer they were in college
you can i think extrapolate this out to
the entire education system these days
which has become just as ideologized
as the
universities were for so many years
people don't know a lot of stuff
this is
part of the the a problem that i have
talked about on this show for a very
long time that sometimes i get some
pushback from the conservatives on
which is that we have always been told
we shouldn't teach students what to
think
only how to think
that's what you're told that's what i
was told when i was coming up through
school i bet that's what most of you
were told you even hear this from
conservatives let's the liberals are
teaching students the leftists
those leftists who indoctrinate rather
than educate they're teaching students
what to think not how to think
this one i'm saying this for the people
in the bleachers
you cannot teach somebody how to think
without teaching them in some way what
to think
you can't teach a student how to think
about math without teaching them that
two plus two equals four you can't teach
a student how to think about
america and american history without
teaching them that the american
revolution begins in earnest in 1776.
you need to teach them
facts about things
you cannot teach a student how to think
about ethics and morality without
teaching the student that it is wrong to
commit murder
when we talk about this distinction
between education and indoctrination
it's usually
a meaningless distinction it's a
distinction without a difference both of
the words mean essentially the same
thing indoctrinate is a word it comes
from the latin word dochere which means
to teach to lead
to educate
to to lead out of your kind of ignorance
into a fuller kind of education which
comes it's got that same root word right
there
the only difference is that we mean
educate to be a good thing and
indoctrinate to be a bad thing it's
always our opponents who are
indoctrinating we're the ones who are
educating
we can't escape the fact that in order
to educate someone properly you've got
to teach them things another terrible
educational movement that occurred while
a lot of us were being educated or not
educated was that we were told oh you
don't need to memorize anything you
don't need to memorize
poems or speeches or dates or people or
events or you don't need to memorize
that because you're so you live in the
future you have google you have your
magical device right here so you can
just look all that up that doesn't
matter you just need to understand
patterns
themes of history not the actual facts
or anything and the libs push this in
particular
because
by having students remain ignorant of
what actually occurred in history
they could just convince students that
they were actually educated because they
believed the highly ideological themes
that we were told about history oh look
you don't need to know anything about
the history of
the united states all you need to know
is the theme that we went from
oppression to freedom
that's the theme don't forget about the
actual stuff that happened
you don't need to know anything about
the history of christianity or the
history of the scientific revolution
or anything all you need to know is we
went from the dark ignorant ages into
the enlightened brilliant scientific
atheist ages that's all you need to know
you don't need to know anything about
what actually happened
and so is it any wonder that now kids
when they're interviewed they don't know
really basic stuff
about their own country
you don't know how many states there are
and when you don't know about your own
country when you don't know about your
own history you don't have any reason to
preserve or conserve it you can't be a
conservative
you couldn't be a conservative even if
you wanted to be a conservative you
wouldn't know what to conserve what are
the schools actually doing the schools
aren't teaching students very much of
anything at all instead they're pushing
a radical ideology especially this trans
stuff and we make fun of it we make fun
of the pronouns we make fun of the crazy
haircuts and
but it's really really harmful to
students there's a florida father who
was just testifying before the state
surgeon general he was describing how
the school that his daughter attended
secretly trans his daughter and this
secret trancing of the daughter led the
daughter to try to kill herself in the
school
in january of 2022 i went to my
daughter's elementary school to deal
with a very sensitive incident my
daughter attempted suicide by hanging in
one of the school bathrooms
my wife and i were told
by the school counselor
that it happened because of an ongoing
issue with her gender identity we were
in shock because
our daughter never showed any signs of
questioning her biological sex
we were told that they knew about the
gender issue
due to meetings they were having with
our daughter
behind our backs
we learned that during these meetings
our daughter
daughter's confusion
was affirmed
and validated through the use of
fictitious male names and male pronouns
our daughter
was living the double life
without our consent or knowledge
this father's restraint is so admirable
imagine especially if you have kids
even if you don't have kids imagine you
do have kids but it's so clear if you do
have kids
you're a sweet little kid aptly your eye
precious you'd do anything you'd throw
yourself in front of a bus for this kid
you send this kid to a school that you
pay for through your taxes
and you assume that you can trust
the people at the school the teachers
and the administrators and then the
teachers and the administrators secretly
fill your precious little kid's head
with lies and fantasies and perverted
delusions and then your kid tries to
kill herself
it would be very difficult to refrain
from violence in that situation
against the perverts and the psychos
and the weirdos at the school who did
that it would be very hard that father
has such admirable
restraint
that's what's going on in our schools
and this is happening in florida that's
why ron desantis has put out this
this mandate to the schools
to say look no more of this
no more of the weird
race education but especially no more of
the weird sex education
up through grade three
the only problem with what's going on in
florida is it doesn't go nearly far
enough
we've got to kick this stuff out of the
classrooms all the way up to grade 12
the weird transgender stuff we just have
to kick it out and if teachers bring
this up at all fire them maybe prosecute
them i don't i don't want to sound
hyperbolic here but this is
an
actual existential threat to society if
men and women don't know
the difference between the two
all right it is a
severe threat to the entire society if
this is what's going on in the education
system and so we have to take it very
very seriously meanwhile the libs are
crying and saying
saying that
ron desantis is basically mussolini
forget mussolini he's hitler that's what
they're saying because he wants to limit
the ability of these sickos in the
guidance counselor offices and the
administrative offices and the
classrooms for that matter to trans your
little daughter and your little son
what are people going to do about it ron
desantis isn't even able to do all that
much this is still going on desantis
gives out his orders and the teachers
laugh and the administrators laugh and
the state attorney's life and they say
yeah we're not going to where okay the
governor gave out his order now let's
see him and force it
i talk a lot on this show about the
squishes
i do because the squishes in some ways
they bug me more than the libs the libs
i expect
i expect them to try to screw up the
country it's the squishes who i find so
deceptive i'm talking about the
kinzingers i'm talking about the liz
cheneys
whose gelatinous rhino spines just
absolutely
morph and melt under the slightest
pressure well it's that kind of behavior
that you would never dream of engaging
in or modeling to your son or daughter
and yet
the numbers
are in right now most of you squished
this very morning some of you are
squishing right now michael you're being
too harsh yeah maybe maybe all right
but if you are still not shaving with a
jeremy's razor
if you're still using a razor made by a
company that said that you're toxic
you are one shaming yourself and two
funding the bizarre gender ideologues
who wish that you would just disappear
down a drain with your unwanted stubble
don't squish on your values swish switch
don't squish switch to jeremy's razors
get your founders series shave kit today
go to jeremysrazors.com
jeremysrazors.com
megan markel is launching a podcast
i'm not interested in this story because
i'm interested in meghan markle i'm not
even interested in this story because
i'm all that interested in podcasts
i'm interested in this story because i'm
really interested in politics and meghan
markle's stupid new podcast tells you
pretty much everything you need to know
about how political power is exercised
in this country
people should expect the real me in this
and probably the me that they've never
gotten to know certainly not in the past
few years
where everything is through the lens of
the media as opposed to hey come to me
i'm just excited to be myself and talk
and be unfiltered and
yeah it's fun
i've said this before i'll say it again
i'm calling for a complete and total
shutdown of new podcasts until we figure
out what the hell is going on too many
people have podcasts look i understand
it's rich coming from me i have three
podcasts myself
okay i've got this show i've got verdict
with ted cruz i've got the book club
i'm on other podcasts actually too i'm
on backstage i get it okay but it's too
much meghan markle having a podcast it's
too much and why does she have a podcast
this woman
was
duchess of sussex this woman was actual
royalty in the most prestigious royal
family in the world the last really even
somewhat important royal family on earth
she wasn't even just a politician she
was even higher than a politician in
public life
and she gave all that up
to do a podcast
she gave up
having a a an official role in politics
to just kind of be in the media
there's a story that came out over the
weekend
this is a story about me actually
and some other people too it's from
politico it was a total hit piece on
conservatives who have podcasts it was
called wow politicians are really bad at
podcasting and none of these politicians
are getting it right and the story was
largely
about me and senator cruz because we
have the
most prominent
politician podcast in the country that's
the verdict podcast which hit number one
on the charts and stayed there for a
long time and it's still is pretty high
up on the charts most of the time and
this politico guy hates the podcast and
he he called me a right wing gadfly
which i'll take as a badge of honor
i'd really be worried if a politico
reporter liked my podcast that's how you
know i'd have to hang it up and find a
new job but i really like he was very
upset he was very bothered he listened
to lots of episodes of the show he
certainly didn't learn anything but
even granted all of that
the very fact that this article could be
written because it wasn't just about me
and ted cruz it was about all of the
politicians who have podcasts as well i
think cruz and i uh senator cruz and i
had the first one and then
afterward it was just this cascade of
politicians starting podcasts sometimes
with co-hosts like me sometimes just on
their own they get a microphone they
record it and see all these politicians
making podcasts and the fact that that
happened tells you a lot about
our political order
which is that
politicians are are starting podcasts
because
there is essentially no difference
between an elected politician and a
media figure in terms of the actual
political influence that they wield in
the country
now
sir obviously if you're in the united
states senate you do still have certain
privileges that the bureaucracy and the
deep state have not managed to take away
from you you can confirm judges you can
ratify treaties
most of the time
but but most of the political power
of elected politicians has gone away
even the u.s senate
which
should be the most important
deliberative body in the world but
certainly the u.s house of
representatives and certainly a lot of
the state houses and certainly a lot of
the lower elected positions
that power has gone away
to the deep state to the bureaucracy
to the executive agencies to the
corporations through privatization
to the schools
to all the rest of it
the difference between
a media figure and a politician
not so clear these days in fact the most
important thing that most elected
politicians do is go on tv well it used
to be go on tv now that tv doesn't
matter as much anymore it's that they go
on podcasts it's that they go on the
internet it's that they get the message
out there
most members of congress are sort of
glorified press secretaries
or now maybe a little bit more so
because they host their own shows and
they get the message out there but in
terms of the real power that they wield
it's not very much
you compare your average member of
congress
to your average career bureaucrat the
bureaucrat has way more power
to your average school administrator
that school administrator is going to
have a whole lot more power
that's a political problem because the
people still have some say with the
elected representative we don't have any
say with those unelected bureaucrats who
even the president can't really fire
you want to talk about difference
between showbiz and politics here and
the overlap ron desantis
who i think is the greatest governor in
the country right now ron desantis
just put out a political ad
where he compares himself to top gun
good morning ladies and gentlemen this
is your governor speaking today's
training evolution dog fighting taking
on the corporate media the rules of
engagement are as follows number one
don't fire unless fired upon but when
they fire you fire back with
overwhelming force
does it say that in the bill
i'm asking you to tell me what's in the
bill number two
never ever
back down from a fight if i could
complete the question though so you're
gonna give a speech or ask a question
number three don't accept their
narrative wrong it's a fake narrative i
just disabused you of the narrative and
you don't care about the facts it's why
people don't trust people like you
because you peddle false narrative all
right ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
as much as i love ron desantis and i
really
love the guy
is as much as i hate this ad
i hate whoever
whoever suggested this ad to the
governor
should not only be fired but should
probably be imprisoned okay
that's how
bad this ad is because the ad
totally cuts against the whole desantis
ethos
the whole desantis vibe
is that he doesn't need to put on a soft
shoe and a show
and
talk himself up and and make a big
spectacle of himself because he's just
really good at governing
that's the the whole argument for
desantis over trump
in
2024 is that desantis has all the really
good qualities of trump he attacks the
media he's got the right instincts he's
right on the issues but he's much more
effective at wielding political power
i'm not saying that's even necessarily
true i'm just saying that's the argument
for desantis over trump
and then desantis goes out and
makes one of these kind of cringe-worthy
commercials
that undercuts that whole argument the
whole argument for desantis is he's a
serious guy no he's he's not messing
around he's not one of these clown
politicians that just goes up and does a
little routine and a little vaudeville
number and doesn't really do anything
the santa is the guy who gets stuff done
he wields political power he's a tough
guy and then they have him put on a
clown suit and dance around what is
wrong with these people
ah
you never
never underestimate the ability of
republican political consultants to
clutch defeat from the jaws of victory
desantis needs to just
forget about this ad politicians make
mistakes but just
he he needs to be aware that he doesn't
have to do this stuff
because he's the real thing he's the
real deal
he could just be the real thing he
doesn't need to be the pretend thing
it's it's the meghan markle problem
meghan markle was the real thing she was
an actual princess
and she gave that up
to try to play disney princesses
she she was an actual public figure
royalty the real deal and she gave that
up
to just be the kind of image of a public
figure to just be a facade to just be
someone on a tv screen
to just play pretend we don't need to
ron desantis doesn't need to play
pretend he's the real thing we all need
to stop playing pretend
we need to actually do stuff
we're live it's a it's a
technological
and social problem it's a problem of our
age we're all just living in virtual
reality
we're all just playing pretend we're all
pretending that that we're a certain
identity on social media i'm not even
talking about media figures or
politicians all of us are doing that
we're putting out a pretend persona
instead of doing the real thing
we're taking photos
that are totally specially tailored to
make it look like we're having a great
time instead of just actually having a
great time to make it look like our
lives are really perfect instead of
actually working on the habitual
virtuous things that make our lives very
good and that lead to human flourishing
don't do that just be the real thing
speaking of potential presidents
you know how much i hate to say i told
you so you're aware of that
for the past couple of weeks
there has been chatter
among the libs
there's been endless wishes and the
whole political class they've said liz
cheney
might run for president in 2024 liz
cheney
standing up against the trumpists and
the magga the liberals on abc news not
just abc news but they're they are i
think representative they were just
discussing all the very serious
commentators with their serious ties on
and sitting on network television and
they said liz cheney oh boy she's going
to pose a real problem for trump she's
going to play a real significant role in
the republican party
mark what what is your sense on
the role that she has
taken on i i think she has been look i
would say that she's unleashed but she
was pretty unleashed before the election
but i think she will be an extremely
relevant figure in her party i think
across the board i i think
she seems like she is one committed not
only to sort of take down donald trump
but to take down the sickness of her
party
extremely relevant the republican party
she's going to take down donald trump
she's going to take down all the mega
people so that's what
the the genius political experts were
saying
on this show
six days ago
i said the opposite i said no liz
cheney's a joke if she ever runs for
president she's not going to take down
trump she's not going to be relevant the
republican party if she does anything at
all she's going to hurt joe biden
so what's her support nation wide among
republicans i don't know negative 10
percent
she would be a spoiler for the democrats
because the democrats have gone
completely insane
even the majority of democrats know that
they've gone completely insane the
majority of democrats don't want joe
biden to win in
or to run even in 2024 and because the
democrats have pumped up liz cheney as
this honorable maverick rogue voice of
reason i could see a lot of moderate
democrats
possibly pulling the lever for her
in 2024. so find by me liz i truly truly
hope she runs
she will not be a problem for the
republicans
guess who was right
guess who is right you've got the whole
stupid political establishment of
experts who are geniuses who go on
network tv on one saying one thing
then you've got little old me
let alone me in my little old studio
saying the opposite guess who was right
turns out
i told you so a uh news new report from
yahoo news and yougov
uh shows that liz cheney if she were to
run for president in 2024 would not only
not take down trump she could
single-handedly swing the election to
trump by hurting the democrats
this poll and yeah it was yahoo and
yugos these are left-wing polls
they found
that if there were a one-on-one rematch
between biden and trump today biden
would lead by four points among
registered voters 46 to 42.
now i don't really believe that that
would happen but that's just to show you
that the poll is skewing to the left
in a three-way race
with liz cheney on the ballot trump
would
flip from being four points down to
having an eight-point lead over joe
biden 40-32 why do i bring it up do i
bring this up just to toot my own horn
no
no not just to do that i bring it up to
remind you and i'm preaching to the
choir here
the people that our society exalts as
experts
are complete idiots who don't know
anything
or who are intentionally misleading you
they are wrong about statistically
everything
they are wrong about liz cheney they
were wrong about trump they were wrong
about russia collusion and ukraine's
collusion we always forget about that
they were wrong about remember net
neutrality repeal all the experts said
that if we repealed net neutrality
people would die remember that they're
wrong about that's just one kind of
random example they were wrong about the
vaccines they were wrong about the masks
even youtube's they're wrong about
everything
they're wrong about everything and so if
you continue to trust them on anything
i can't help you you're not gonna make
it and i know i know that even for us
hardened conservatives who we don't have
really any trust in the establishment
anymore but even for us when you see the
fancy people in the fancy ties on
network tv and they've got really fancy
faces you know and they look really
serious
and they say listen she's going to be a
really relevant figure in her party
oh yeah global warming is going to kill
us all in nine years uh-huh oh the masks
totally work they super duper work the
vaccine if you take the vaccines you'll
you'll never get coveted and you won't
spread it and we're really serious
people it's it's hard to
it's hard to push back against that
because
they are they at least have the facade
the veneer of authority
they don't have any real credibility but
it sort of seems like they do i had this
experience i may have mentioned it on
the show i went to my 10-year college
reunion and i got to see a lot of my
friends some of whom are former friends
because they don't like
my political activities in recent years
but
i would say probably a fifth of the
class we had a nice time hung out had a
good had a good time and a lot of the
rest of the class not only were they
frowning at me but they were frowning in
general i noticed this a lot of a lot of
my
classmates i went to a very liberal
school
and a lot of these people have gone on
to have
according to the
new york times according to the kind of
elite consensus they've had really
good lives they they did all the things
they were supposed to do
they
went to the fancy school they didn't
settle down and get married they worked
in some kind of
liberal
company that that is considered
prestigious they didn't prioritize their
personal life they they moved to the big
city they lived in a little pod they
went to all the restaurants that you're
supposed to go to they only prioritized
work and they read the new york times
and they read the atlantic and they just
did all the stuff that the liberal
establishment tells you to do and all
the experts tell you to do and they lock
down
they wore the masks and they get all the
shots and they
they take all the advice of the libs
and they're miserable
so many of them
you look at feminism the feminism which
is
one of the most effective political
movements in american history certainly
of the last 50 60 years
feminism said we are going to make women
happier
ever since feminism took over in the
1960s women have become much less happy
both in relative terms to men and in
absolute terms
it didn't it's not it doesn't give you
what it promises it will give you the
experts
the emperor has no clothes the experts
have no wisdom
you really should not believe them
one last point on that liz jenny bit i
just noticed people call her a maverick
you know and it reminds me of one last
point on the stupid ron desantis ad
they
it's just occurring to me now
they
they are comparing ron desantis to
maverick they're saying he's a maverick
maverick is the term in politics most
associated with john mccain who is the
opposite kind of republican that
desantis is john mccain not popular
anymore totally squished on the
republicans when it counted deeply
unpopular in the party you've got ron
desantis who doesn't squish who's a
tough guy who's conservative who's very
popular and this stupid ad it's just
hitting me now
is implicitly comparing him to john
mccain by calling him a maverick what
are the ah what are these people
thinking drives me crazy drives me
absolutely crazy
don't do that don't believe the experts
whether you're talking about the expert
washington dc political consultants are
you talking about the experts in the lab
coats at the nih or anywhere in between
these guy i'm not saying experts always
are idiots but right now they are and
you shouldn't believe them
now speaking of hurting democrats as liz
jenny would do
a new york city official
is uh still crying about the fact that
texas governor greg abbott is shipping
up buses of illegal aliens from texas to
new york because new york says we want
more and more illegal immigration texas
says we really don't new york says we're
a sanctuary city and so texas says okay
you want them you got them they ship
them up and now the new yorkers are
crying and they're saying no we don't
actually want them we just want to make
you look bad we want you to keep them we
don't actually want them and now
obviously that's so hypocritical
people are are
mocking
new york city because governor rabbit
called their bluff and it became clear
that the new york democrats only want
illegal immigration
elsewhere in the red states but not in
my backyard now the new york city
officials are trying to
explain that away they're trying to
explain their reticence to take on the
illegal aliens that they've encouraged
to come to america it's because they say
they didn't get any warning
cities in texas have been dealing with
this issue for decades and now new york
city washington d.c dealing with the
same issues right now i want to put
something on the screen right now this
is from the new york times they've been
covering this pretty in depth and this
is from over the weekend they wrote the
city's early response to the influx of
migrants was marked by weeks of flailing
and missteps deeply at odds with the
give me your huddled mass masses
rhetoric of mayor eric adams some
families slept at an intake office in
the bronx in violation of the law some
were separated by bureaucratic snafus
and advocates said the city often failed
to provide basics like food diapers and
medical attention this is new york city
this is supposed to be the greatest city
in the world so what's happening
again governor avid uh did not give us
any warning that he would be sending
people to new york city
and as non-profits like catholic
charities have indicated they started to
um receive people out of nowhere and
it's it's a situation that we are all
trying to adjust
and and meet the moment
that's it no we would have really been
happy with all the illegal aliens being
shipped up here from texas it's just we
didn't get any warning
what do you mean you didn't get any
warning
are you telling me that illegal
immigration is some new issue in america
this hasn't been going on for
50 years now
increasingly
oh yeah we just had no idea what are you
talking about you know about illegal
immigration that's why you call yourself
a sanctuary state that's why you call
for more of it
you just didn't think
you didn't think
that the
governors would call your bluff
you d what happened here is you didn't
believe
when you you thought that you could just
talk talk talk talk talk oh yeah we want
illegal immigrants we're the good guys
those texas people they're the bad guys
oh we would take them we would totally
take them we love illegal immigration
and you didn't think that any republican
would actually wield political power to
call your bluff because you thought that
republicans are all gelded little gimps
who
just exist to lose with dignity
and they maybe they occasionally talk a
good game but they don't actually wield
power and then greg abbott who's not
even the most right-wing conservative
greg abbott wielded power in just a
little bit little bitty way and you're
losing your minds that's a good message
for all the rest of the republicans
because by the way this is popular stuff
i mentioned on the show the other day
that the majority of americans believe
that illegal immigration constitutes an
invasion
and the libs say this is racist horrible
rhetoric the poll comes out by ipsos
shows that 47 of hispanics agree that
illegal immigration across the border is
an invasion almost half of the hispanics
in this country i don't think they're
racist against hispanics they're saying
the same thing because it's true it's a
winning issue republicans just need to
wield a little bit of that
power
now we've got a lot more coming up in
the member block uh our producers have
found
a uh
a viral clip on tick tock of
what they tell me is the most intense
pronoun explanation this is going to
clear up all the pronoun transgender
controversy they want to play it for me
this way i'll become educated i'll
probably become woke that is happening
right now if you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us over at
daily wire we'll see you over there
[Music]
[Music]
you